play quick little video for you then
just sit back and relax while you're in
the flight it's important to relax the
waiver you sign states that you are
fully aware you can be seriously injured
or even killed as a result of these
activities this is called ultimate
bucket list we're all going to choose
items from our bucket list to determine
what belongs on the ultimate bucket list
we're here in
[Music]
it's not the most Vegas II of shots is
it we're in residential Las Vegas access
to something on your bucket list like
what do you really wanna do you know
what
like I would actually be really good at
it is trapeze for like circus school
yeah kind of like Beyonce on tour a lot
I actually saw in section the city okay
check you out
[Music]
it's up pretty high yeah it is high it's
high yeah it's like high high are you
scared of heights not like we're not
doing Cirque de Soleil Heights I mean I
don't know maybe what's up guys my name
is Renato Fernandez and today we're here
in the Las Vegas circus Center everybody
here is either then instruct us on a or
worse for Cirque du Soleil right now you
know this place is huge you don't have
everything we have flying trapeze Ninja
Warrior course Russian swing a fitness
center trampoline this place is crazy
they have literally everything here it
is an adult playground for sure
that's just like neat herself in the
face and it started bleeding it was wild
man even though she kneed herself in the
face I think she's gonna do great I
believe in her rich I don't know he
seems really scared those massive signs
are freaking me out and we got a
defibrillator so you're gonna be fine
trying to contain my my freak out my
internal freak out a little bit I don't
like Heights
this is essence this thing I'm gonna
gain face it I'm gonna try but
underneath I'm gonna be shaking so I'm
all cleans up now but on my pants as you
can see my face is just in different
areas so right here is blood this is
lipstick from when I kissed myself when
I need myself so if I can't handle
myself on a trampoline I'm kind of
scared about how I will do on the
trapeze thingamajig that I don't know
what it's called
whoa oh my gosh
our goal for today is go upside down
hang by your knees all right who's gonna
be the first one he's asking the
impossible here
even getting off the thing it's a
ridiculous it back you know I'm still
know like there's so much there dude is
freaking out there so I'm pretty sure
that I'm gonna have fun right now look
at his face we're gonna say this is a
kid over here he's thinking about it
this ladder is so wobbly I'm not I won't
never be ready for this I'm gonna yank
him forward a little bit and he's gonna
freak out like this
whoa yeah I literally cannot bend my
knees
oh my god
hey okay Pedro come help me sorry buddy
can you flex for the camera
well close getting the most epic part of
the day right now the catch is gonna
catch you guys at the end sorry could
you say that one more time
what could this guy
[Music]
I really don't want to do it again and
do the whole like flip over my head to
get caught by the bloke I don't don't
need to do that
[Music]
No
tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now it's too fun I don't know if you
could beat that I don't think I could
beat it because a lot of height stuff is
a little predictable it's like skydiving
bungee jumping I don't want a bungee job
is it gonna be predictable or you got
something a little bit why don't you
guys we're going on flotsam watch the
name threw me off like a superhero and
it's 5 o'clock so what does it mean you
play like a superhero
yeah my name is Patrick Hughes on the
president and CEO of the Fremont Street
Experience which is ultimately six city
block pedestrianised special event
concert area anchored on top by the
world's largest LED screen this is
absolutely the longest zipline
experience in the country rich is
actually handling Heights pretty well is
it safe is it a hundred percent safe I
don't think anything is however we have
an outstanding safety record we just
have a little bit of a scaredy-cat
that's why it's not really anything like
Vegas in England there's a town called
Blackpool but yeah I don't need to say
much about that place I also quite
likely because it's not competitive
Jasmine's very competitive if there's a
way for someone to be better she'll find
it
it's slim tonight you see other people
and they start swimming or they're gonna
slow in themselves now let's go this way
wait you just get a tip is lazy getting
tips are we racing each other or we go
at the same speed or is there any
competition element absolutely there's
our Titian it's already way taller than
I thought it would
when you of course you get pushed off
rich has just been really dramatic
holiday you can catch them being like oh
no I can't do this but I think he's
gonna really enjoy this one because you
just got to sit there and fly through
the air like a bird and that feels
amazing it's a little bit disconcerting
because you can't actually see where
you're heading or what's in front of you
you know when you're like at the top of
a waterslide or a roller coaster you can
see what's ahead there's just a garage
door there's no I don't know it's gonna
happen
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that was amazing your brakes work they
do work that's the whole point
it better be fun it's fun I'm gonna
preface mine by saying I know it's a
little bit controversial okay
it's skydiving but indoors indoor
skydiving could be cool yeah
you guys are not excited at all it's
like the energy kind of confused is it
that air tube thing I've wanted to try
that so that's what it is I'm excited
about it good you're not showing it but
I'll take your word for it
Jasmine come on give me for it I think
it's a great choice yeah I love when air
just blow that me you know it's just a
great item you wait it looks really
really
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to Vegas your skydivin yeah grab
you see it get comfortable my name is
rich in the beard instructor alright
I'll play a quick little video for you
teach everything you need to sit back
and relax while you're in the flight is
important
[Music]
the waiver you sign states that you are
fully aware you can be seriously injured
or even killed as a result of these
activities if you have any questions
please feel free to talk to your
instructor before your flight there's a
bunch of air like gushing out the ground
and you're like but this is not a hight
thing I don't know well I do know why
rich picked this because he's scared of
heights
that being said I think it's gonna be
really fun woah rich Jasmine's give me
I'm sure she says it's not you know it's
not nothing to do with Heights it's not
real skydiving she's gone skydiving 200
times did rich tell you about how I went
skydiving super super excited super
pumped but I feel like it's gonna be a
little bit challenging at first because
you have to just kind of like surrender
your body to the wind essence does not
surrender but I feel super safe - the
you know disclaimer that we could die
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm so excited feeling good I just
burped you just burped I did look I'm
good it just smells like tuna
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was insane
no phenomenal indoor skydiving is
checked off the list he totally did it
on purpose
trapeze was so fun
it was like being five but on an adult
swing oh wait not that one I didn't even
go there SWAT Zilla was awesome i won
did you realize yeah I did I feel like
the feeling that I was chasing with
wanting to fly with trapeze oh I
actually got it and our skydiving so
what are we gonna choose I already know
I know - whoa I know - okay off two
three three two one I don't know if I
could do it again oh I never know what
it is now we won't ever do it again
[Music]
[Music]